kiew erwartet krieg
vor den toren der ukrainischen
hauptstadt trainieren sie in wehr
übungen für den ernstfall
im parlament schreiben die abgeordneten
einen brandbrief an den deutschen
bundestag und zitieren martin luther
king am ende werden wir uns nicht an die
worte unserer feinde erinnern sondern an
das schweigen unserer freunde
bedauerlicherweise ist der einfluss
derjenigen stark die einfach zurück
wollen zum 'business as usual' mit der
russischen föderation und diese
ökonomischen interessen treiben die
entscheidungen der deutschen regierung
an
olaf scholz hat lange gezögert erst
mitte januar und erst unter erheblichem
druck legt er die gaspipeline nord
stream zwei als sanktionsinstrument
gegen russland auf den tisch einige nato
partner liefern längst waffen an die
ukraine die bundesregierung lehnt das
kategorisch ab die 5000 helme die
deutschland stattdessen verspricht
kommen beim bündnispartner usa an wie
ein schlechter witz
ben hodges war lange kommandeur der us
streitkräfte in europa er sagt
deutschlands verhalten sei frustrierend
und beim thema waffenlieferungen einfach
heuchelei
ich glaube ägypten ist einer der größten
kunden der deutschen waffenindustrie und
daran ist nichts falsches aber natürlich
befindet sich ägypten im konflikt mit
dem yemen und mit libyen also warum
warum ist es okay denen waffen für
hunderte millionen euro zu verkaufen und
nicht der ukraine
der nato-partner estland teilt eine
grenze mit russland und fühlt sich
selbst latent bedroht aktuell will
estland artilleriegeschütze an die
ukraine weiter geben die ursprünglich
aus ddr beständen stammen die deutsche
regierung aber blockiert dass
man sagt dass wir mit der lieferung der
waffen die russen und provozieren ich
bin fest überzeugt dass der gegensatz
der fall ist weil wir provozieren durchs
land wenn wir nichts machen
wir bieten ja nicht um truppen auf
ukrainischem boden aber andere länder
davon abzuhalten die ukraine mit waffen
zu versorgen das ist und entschuldigen
sie dass ich das so sage widerlich
gemeinsam mit frankreich hat deutschland
das sogenannte normandie format wieder
aufgenommen eine vierer
verhandlungsrunde mit russland und der
ukraine
substanzielle fortschritte gab es beim
ersten treffen nicht für die übernächste
woche ist ein zweites in berlin geplant
an deutsche zögerlichkeit und deutsches
leise treten hat sich frankreich
gewöhnen müssen
es gibt die gewohnheit dass die deutsche
diplomatie seit jahrzehnten
immer wieder versucht
bei jedem angenehm zu sein und nicht
lauter zu sprechen als die anderen aber
auch zugleich die eigenen interessen
wirklich definitiv zu vertreten und
diese zögerlichkeit ist ja sozusagen ein
markenzeichen der deutschen diplomatie
ralf fücks war lange außenpolitischer
vordenker der grünen inzwischen leitete
er einen fink schwerpunkt osteuropa
fuchs sagt deutschland müsse
außenpolitisch endlich die augen öffnen
ich glaube dass wir mental immer noch in
den 90er jahren sind also in der
forschung es gibt keine gegner mehr und
wir fahren jetzt die friedensdividende
einrüsten einseitig massiv ab und diese
phase ist tatsächlich vorüber wir müssen
auch den stellenwert von militär in der
sicherheitspolitik neu überdenken und
bereits sein mehr in unsere sicherheit
zu investieren
deutschlands partner wünschen sich
initiative klarheit und handlungswillen
deutschland liefert gerade genau das
gegenteil